In 2007, Sony released the Nic Cage superhero
flick Ghost Rider, which was both spooky and
cheesy in equal measure, and in 2012, it got
a sequel, Ghost Rider: Spirit of Vengeance.
But since the rights to Ghost Rider have reverted
to Marvel, there's been no sign of a third
movie ever happening.
Here's why Marvel won't give Ghost Rider another
movie.
Box office meh
While the first Ghost Rider film earned a
decent $228 million worldwide, the second
only managed $132 million, which is less than
Tony Stark carries in his wallet for petty
cash.
"Ya, big man in a suit of armor.
Take that off what are you?"
"Genius, billionaire, playboy, philanthropist."
Considering both films were also lambasted
by movie critics, there's not much reason
for Marvel to put out another Ghost Rider
film when they have proven properties like
Captain America and Spider-man to focus on
instead, not to mention new franchises like
Captain Marvel and Black Panther.
Nic Cage isn't interested
Even if the stars somehow aligned and Marvel
did decide to tackle a third Ghost Rider film
with Cage, the actor has indicated he's not
really all that keen to climb back on the
motorcycle, given the chance.
As he told Collider,
"I've said what I have to say.
I don't want to say never…anything's possible.
But I doubt, highly, that I would be in a
third installment of that."
We're guessing most fans aren't exactly disappointed
with that news.
Television
Though he's not on the big screen anymore,
there are still some Ghost Rider stories being
told in live action—they're just happening
on Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. series.
"You don't get to decide who deserves to die."
"I'm not the one who decides."
The newest Ghost Rider, Robbie Reyes, is played
by Gabriel Luna and has quickly become a fan
favorite.
Though ratings are down, the introduction
of Ghost Rider has revitalized the show, providing
a connection to the mystical side of the MCU
opened up by the big-screen hit Doctor Strange.
Team-up, anyone?
Marvel's great divide
Fans hoping that Robbie Reyes' appearance
in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. might be planting
the seeds for the newest Ghost Rider to jump
on to the big screen are probably going to
be disappointed.
"Claims he made a deal with the devil."
"Which is nonsense."
"Ya know the rationalist in me wants to agree
but, the skull on fire presents a pretty compelling
argument for hail Satan."
So far, the events in the movies have had
only a minor effect on the television series,
while the stuff on the TV shows hasn't even
been mentioned in the movies.
"I guess you guys haven't heard about me."
This is probably because of a long-running
power struggle between movie studio head Kevin
Feige and Marvel president Ike Perlmutter,
who is still in charge of the TV shows.
As long as there continues to be backstage
drama between the two, Ghost Rider is probably
stuck where he is: on television, and not
in the movies.
Johnny Blaze is old news
The version of Ghost Rider that Nic Cage played,
Johnny Blaze, seems to just be part of the
current Ghost Rider's backstory in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Though Cage himself didn't appear on Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D., the origin story for Robbie
Reyes involved Robbie making a deal with the
devil in order to save his brother's life.
"And you're right, there was someone there
when I came to.
But it wasn't a good samaritan...it was the
devil."
Add in the fact that the show also teased
Quentin Carnival, the carnival that Jonny
Blaze works for, and it seems as though Johnny's
story is just prologue in the MCU.
Of course, Marvel could always do a prequel
series about Johnny's time as Ghost Rider,
but we sort of already have that in the form
of Sony's two films.
No more crap
The first Ghost Rider movie hit just before
the comic book movie creative renaissance
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe—back when
studios could still get away with releasing
mediocre comic book adaptations.
In terms of quality and tone, the Ghost Rider
films have far more in common with last-generation
superhero movies like Daredevil and Fantastic
Four than they do with modern films like Iron
Man or The Dark Knight.
Given the poor reputation the Ghost Rider
films have, it's unlikely Marvel would risk
tainting their perfect record at the box office
with a franchise that carries so much baggage.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!